bioshock 2 is perfection it took what
was wrong with bioshock 1 and changed it
for the better but it also kept its
strongest narrative devices in the game
making it feel like how a bioshock game
should this ultimately created a perfect
version of bioshock that i feel doesn't
get enough credit so today i want to
discuss why i think that without further
ado
let's get started as always we need to
start at the beginning a cutscene
showcases that we are in 1958. if you
recall from the lore that is only a year
before the new year's attacks in 1959.
so currently things should be quite
civil and for the most part they are we
see a first person view of a big daddy
talking with a little sister to which he
follows her around the halls she ends up
running on a head before getting caught
by some thugs just like any big daddy
would he decimates the thugs with ease
before being hypnotized afterwards
though a woman named sophia lam enters
the room
there we are
he's perfectly safe now
this is not your daughter
do you understand
her name is eleanor and she is mine
now
neil please
remove your helmet
now
take the pistol
place it against your head
[Music]
fire
honestly it's a great intro and we can
learn a lot from it firstly while
walking with a little sister we get a
sneak peek at the big daddy guiding her
and it's a model we haven't seen yet in
the series on top of that the little
girl has a name eleanor throughout the
series we aren't told little sister's
name so this was done intentionally to
paint her as an important character even
further we actually see the big daddy
remove his helmet this is also a first
for the series as we know big daddies
were regular people who had
modifications done to their body so they
could fit the role of the big daddy such
as voice modification mental
conditioning and the grafting of the
skin to the suit itself but this doesn't
seem to be the case the only character
who who's capable of doing this is jack
and bioshock 1 but as we know he only
needed to seem like a big daddy so he
could bypass the facility's lockdown if
you want to see more of this i did talk
about bioshock 1 in a previous video
which will be linked at the end of this
one or in the eye in the top right right
now so questions are already flooding
the player's mind and it's enough to
either get them hooked immediately or at
least get their attention mind you this
is only three minutes into the game so
we're starting off quite strong bioshock
1 had the element of surprise as the
player wasn't accustomed to rapture just
yet that's why it's sudden reveal landed
so well but doing that again wouldn't
have the same effect so bioshock 2
needed to ramp up the intensity and not
only does the intro start off incredibly
strong it keeps going as the character
we play throughout the game is a big
daddy words can't describe how excited i
was when seeing this there is no doubt
in my mind that at least once the rada
playthrough of bioshock won you must
have thought how cool it would have been
to play as one while our prayers have
been answered as playing as the big
daddy is arguably the greatest feeling
in the series from the actual
moment-to-moment gameplay to the
interactions with the little sisters the
big daddy is such a great character for
the player to control as if all this
wasn't great already the game introduces
the newest character to the roster the
big sister these two represent a sort of
dichotomy battling over a common goal
quite early in the game we take our
first plasmid and come across a little
sister since we're a big daddy our duty
is to obviously protect her except the
big sister swipes her away from us the
problem is that the big sisters were
designed to also protect the little
sisters so firstly where did she even
come from but secondly why are they
actively working against us despite
having a common goal bioshock as a
series has never shielded away from
secrecy mystery and confusion especially
in its early moments already within just
a few minutes we're given multiple
breadcrumb trails and while not forced
to follow said trail why wouldn't you
after going through this intro who is
the big sister who are we why aren't we
a normal big daddy who's eleanor and who
is sophia lamb these questions are the
driving force behind why the player
continues deeper into the game bioshock
2 had a tough job of continuing the
series after the very satisfying
conclusion of the previous game it also
had to get the player interested despite
giving all of its secrets away in that
previous game and somehow bioshock 2
nailed it perfectly some games have been
able to pull this off before but only
few have been truly able to do this
within a couple minutes of game time and
the fact that bioshock 2 can replicate
the same mysterious feeling of bioshock
1 with the added penalty of having its
vast world building already known by the
player deserves some praise so now that
i'm done rambling about the game's
mystery i think it's time to finally
explain that mystery i've always been a
sucker for lore in games if it wasn't
evident by the videos on this channel
and bioshock 2's newly added concepts in
world building are utterly brilliant
just like bioshock 1 the majority of the
story will come from audio diaries
random devices we can find throughout
the world however bioshock 1 ran into an
issue with these devices many of the
audio diaries focused on key characters
whether that was the main boss of an
area like dr steinmann or was a part of
rapture's high society like tenenbaum
and andrew ryan it felt like rapture
only revolved around a few people and
that never sat right with me bioshock 2
changes this completely as while some
notable characters will have numerous
appearances throughout the game like
sophia lam andrew ryan and tenenbaum
there's also a large number of audio
logs made by just random people who had
way more world building than bioshock 1
ever did we'll circle back to him in a
moment but a good example is mark
meltzer his audio diaries detail his
investigation into rapture and his
daughter sydney as he believes his
daughter was kidnapped and brought here
for an unknown reason originally it
seems like just a one-off diary but not
only does just this one diary explain
that people from the surface have found
an invaded rapture but he has more
diaries that show up throughout the game
and it makes you want to see the outcome
of his investigation like i said even if
it was just a one-off diary the fact
that people like mark can even find
rapture is incredible to begin with
rapture was built to be away from
society both far and deep enough that
only those who were invited would know
yet somehow random people are able to
find it and that's a big issue just this
one diary finally provided an
astronomical amount of world building
and makes rapture feel like a living
breathing city besides the miscellaneous
audio diaries a good portion of them
still deal with a lot of information
that is necessary to understanding
what's going on so the intro was in 1958
but the game actually takes place 10
years later in 1968. we are subject
delta and alpha series big daddy not
only are we a part of the first line of
big daddies but we're the first ever big
daddy to be bonded with a little sister
on top of this being an alpha series is
quite different than being a regular big
daddy firstly alpha series big daddies
don't have the skin grafted to their
suit which explains why delta could take
off his helmet in the intro furthermore
the alpha series is only intended to
bond with one little sister during their
creation the person inside the suit was
fitted with an unbreakable psychological
bond with one little sister should this
bond be broken by the death of the
little sister or the separation of the
two for an extended period of time the
alpha series will either collapse and
enter a coma-like state or be driven mad
with rage one of the audio diaries even
talks about someone seeing one of the
alpha series big daddies crying at a
gatherer's garden because they couldn't
find their little sister this idea
clearly had many drawbacks as the big
daddies would be completely useless
should the little sister die this is why
they changed the typical big daddies we
see more frequently in bioshock 1. ones
who still protect the little sisters but
don't have a specific bond with a
particular one making them a bit more
useful this unbreakable bond we just
discussed is why delta is so adamant on
finding eleanor when he awakes but
clearly he wasn't just a suit of armor
all his life as we know all big daddies
were humans at some point in delta's
case he was just a deep-sea diver on the
surface who accidentally came across
rapture he actually had an article
written in the paper about him ryan
didn't believe this story and thought
that he was a spy so he had him
incarcerated his old life would then
come to an end when he was selected to
be a part of the big daddy program
leaving his old name and identity behind
being only known as delta after the
cutscene in the intro delta wakes up
after the events of bioshock 1. so
andrew ryan and fontaine are already
dead the first words we hear upon waking
up are from a familiar voice tenenbaum
it seems that even though rapture is
practically a barren wasteland she
decided to stay behind or at least
that's what it seems like tenenbaum
actually came back to rapture thanks to
sophia lamb rapture is an extremely
captivating place not just in ideals but
in location substitute out that
objectivism that andrew ryan brought
into the city and swapped that with
literally anything and you can get a
ultimate utopia of that ideal rapture is
a secluded place away from the rest of
the world so literally anything involved
with rapture could have blossomed from
such a location like let's say a cult
rapture in bioshock 2 is now under new
management with sofia lam being the
leader who has rallied the people behind
the banner of the family you may
actually recognize sophia as throughout
the first game there was a poster
showing rapture's best and brightest and
in the back resides sophia before and
during her time in rapture she was a
clinical psychiatrist anger ryan had
invited her to rapture so that she could
provide counseling to the isolated
members of rapture overall it sounded
like a great deal for both parties
involved but sophia quickly realized
that the cause of this problem was the
person who hired her to solve it andrew
ryan see rapture under ryan was built
around objectivism something i had
completely neglected to bring up in the
previous video so thank you all the
comments for mentioning that to me
objectivism is defined as quote the
concept of man as a heroic being with
his own happiness as the moral purpose
of his life with productive achievement
as his noblest activity and reason as
his only absolute but sophia had a more
altruistic look on life as she had hoped
to enlighten the citizens of rapture
through a common good she would do this
by providing free therapy to the poor
and intentionally losing at poker so she
could spread her wealth to the less
fortunate anger ryan actively wanted the
people to push themselves and seek their
true greatness on their own without
anyone hindering their progress but
sophia was actively going against that
by helping others this caused the two to
clash heads on multiple occasions even
having live debates on specific topics
and it was also during this time that
sophia was actively helping the poor and
fontaine was also trying to undermine
ryan using fontaine futuristics so when
it was discovered that both fontaine and
ryan were dead it made sense that she
became the newest owner her altruistic
outlook on life also helped her gain
that favor as the people of rapture saw
her as a kind of woman willing to help
those who were less fortunate but she
knew this wouldn't last she would either
be overtaken by some other force of
nature or she would die from natural
causes so to continue her goals she
ended up teaching her daughter in hopes
of becoming her perfect vessel eleanor
is her daughter yes the little sister
that delta had bonded with is none other
than the new queen of rapture's daughter
it's such a great twist and it raises
the stakes of our missions tenfold so
far this is the story of rapture in
bioshock 2 but i've neglected to bring
up tenenbaum as i said tenenbaum did
leave rapture and so did all the little
sisters but she discovered that more
girls were disappearing so she came back
to rapture to find out someone was
making little sisters again so she came
down here to put an end to it as you
remember tenenbaum was the creator of
the little sisters but after she
realized the pain in suffering this
cause she regretted her actions and
dedicated her time to stopping what she
created but now she has to do it all
over again this is the full complete
backstory that sets the foundation of
bioshock 2. it's quite a lot and can get
complex at times but this is exactly
what i was looking for i wanted bioshock
2 to take the already established story
of bioshock 1 and make that the
foundation for the sequel and this
integration exceeded my expectations so
far we've been getting a little ahead of
ourselves so let's dial it back a bit
and continue where we left off in game
currently we're still in the early
minutes of the game and already sofia's
cult like following is starting to show
itself as there are paintings tributes
and murals dedicated to her there's no
shortage of these in bioshock 2 truly
showing how far her influence goes in
rapture and alternatively how alone and
outnumbered we are again accompanying
these tributes is a book called unity
and metamorphosis it's all about the
creation of a perfect paradise through
unity and the abandonment of the self
this also coincides with all the imagery
and messages of butterflies and being
reborn just as a caterpillar is reborn
into a butterfly a butterfly is vastly
different compared to a caterpillar
which is why it's considered two
different insects despite being the same
thing sophia planned on using eleanor as
a vessel for her ideologies by basically
shutting her away from the world while
she teaches her she would then show the
family eleanor and how she is the first
utopian who was able to abandon herself
and become truly free the problem is
that sophia has to convince the rest of
rapture to do the same and while many
are on her side aligning herself with
her is a lot different than changing
your way of thinking permanently
thankfully depending on how you look at
it sophia did find a rather interesting
discovery sophia discovered the story of
jack and realized that this mental
conditioning could be used to make
people uphold the common good this
proves that sofia is just as flawed as
everyone else she is literally following
in the footsteps of fontaine and is
considering using a type of conditioning
that reprograms the brain and forces
people not to think for themselves just
like we talked about before this is
another example of bioshock 2 taking key
parts from the previous game and
reworking it in the sequel now the
phrase would you kindly isn't seen as a
way to manipulate someone to do your
bidding but it's seen as a necessary
step to be able to live freely in a
utopia it's these slight twists on
already familiar material that makes the
story very engaging again continuing
through the level we finally get to face
off against the big sister and it's here
and a few other places later in the game
via audio diaries where we discover
where these big sisters came from these
big sisters were originally little
sisters the atom in their body became
too problematic as they grew older and
thus the older sisters were moved into
different roles we also find out that it
was the big sisters who were abducting
the new little sisters from the surface
which explains the vast population of
little sisters still in rapture again
there isn't any other lore besides this
but it does answer a fairly good
question in regards to what happens when
the sisters get older irrational games
could have easily just said that because
rapture is so large we didn't rescue all
the little sisters thus why they're
still populating the city but this
approach to its world building was a
much better choice so nice job as we
approach the end of the first area we
encounter sophia for the first time very
similarly to how we encounter ryan
except instead of atlas trying to help
us it's tenenbaum she then explains that
she can help us get to eleanor or she
can see through the camera in our helmet
except i'm not really even sure why they
brought this up as it's never used again
we meet tenonbomb one time in person and
then afterwards we never hear another
word from her we get more info on her
whereabouts and time and rapture from
audio diaries again which is a shame as
these audio diaries tell us a lot of
important information that i would have
loved for her to elaborate on now to be
fair these audio logs are in the dlc
which we'll talk about later but still i
wish that she would have had much more
of an appearance this game instead we're
going to be guided by augustus sinclair
and i 100
blame bioshock 1 for this because i did
not trust him the entire game he feels
the exact same role as atlas a guy we
don't know who just wants to help us for
seemingly no reason but the whole time
he was talking i was just waiting for
him to backstab us but it never came
true upon entering the second area we
hear eleanor's voice and discover that
she can talk to us telepathically and is
actively trying to aid us by bringing us
gifts and plasmids it's not clear how
she can do this but it's explained later
one thing you'll notice from playing
this game is the lack of levels in
bioshock 2. the game only has 9 areas
compared to its predecessor's 14 and
while that's not a large difference it's
still a lesser amount but what bioshock
2 lacks in quantity it makes up for in
quality each of these levels is 3 4 or 5
levels high filled with rubble objects
enemies and other gear for the player to
look at these places feel lived in and
real which is always a nice feeling
you'll be spending much more time in
these levels individually than compared
to bioshock 1. both games did take me
around the same time to complete yet one
game had less levels than the other
meaning i was spending more time in
those levels engaging with the
environment and dealing with puzzles and
all the enemies it threw at me bioshock
1 also did feel quite linear at times
places like the proving grounds and the
medical pavilion were great but some of
the levels felt way too linear for the
genre all of the levels in bioshock 2
are completely non-linear you'll be
constantly backtracking to the same
places and not only does this add to the
gameplay loop of finding new enemies in
the same locations but it also plays
into the story and how it's continually
trying to reinforce how large these
areas within rapture are and how
expansive this city really is my only
complaint is the odd amount of
similarity between some of the levels as
sometimes it's hard to determine what
level you're really on besides a few
specific areas bioshock 1 really nailed
the diversity of the level to level
gameplay to where no level really looked
the same i will admit though that this
is quite the subjective stance however
something that is objectively better
than before is the way the game handles
the little sisters in our last video
talking about bioshock 1 i mentioned
that while on paper the choice of saving
and harvesting the little sisters was
cool in practice it was extremely
one-sided as it favored rescuing the
little sisters thus ruining the choice
of morality bioshock 2 reduces the
number of little sisters from 21 down to
12. on top of this rescuing the little
sister requires you to defeat the big
daddy protecting her then escort her to
two bodies in the level to extract adam
from once that's done only then can you
rescue them this is made way more
difficult thanks to bioshock 2's amp
difficulty the game isn't impossible but
you start out with a max of 5 eve and
health slots rather than your 9 in
bioshock 1. your weapons also don't feel
nearly as powerful sometimes and enemies
do hit a lot harder plus there's also
more big daddies as you'll be constantly
fighting more alpha series versions as
we get closer to the game's epilogue
furthermore every 4 little sisters that
you rescue or harvest will spawn a big
sister who while does drop 40 atom is
without a doubt the hardest enemy in the
game after everything is all said and
done upon looking at the numbers the
actual difference isn't that far off
it's actually less than the previous
game with a difference of 90 atom
according to the wiki but the tasks
required to get that atom makes
harvesting seem like the much better
option as if all this wasn't bad enough
already something we discover from the
audio logs later in the game is that the
little sisters despite being immortal do
experience some degree of pain as one
fell over a railing and broke her leg
and when they tried to snap it back into
place it was clear from her facial
reactions that she was experiencing pain
makes you think about the next time you
unload a few rockets near her when you
try to take down the big daddy relating
back to the story this is what
irrational games had intended for the
first game giving the player an easy but
morally wrong option and a hard but
morally right option to see if it's
enough to break the player's values is
the struggle to hold off waves of
splicers enough to make you snap and
just take the atom for yourself by force
this idea also makes the ending much
more important but we'll get to that
later the fourth area of the game is
popper's drop and is our first instance
of a boss-like character similar to dr
steinman from bioshock 1. in this area
we have grace holloway who runs this
section of rapture and is eagerly
waiting to kill us according to the
audio logs we find about her grace was a
singer here in rapture who caught the
eye of a james who was enjoying her
singing he seemed to enjoy when people
were real when it came to rapture and
willing to talk about its flaws this
caused him to be noticed by ryan and
then taken away never to be heard of
again she would then hear of sophia lamb
and how she was giving away a free
counseling and then was swindled into
her family she joined her group of
people and because of how important she
was to sophia when ryan eventually came
for sophia and locked her up in prison
she gave eleanor to grace so that she
may look after her however this didn't
last long as eleanor was kidnapped and
sold to the little sister's orphanage
which explains how she became a little
sister in the first place once she
became a little sister she would then
bond to us and we would then become her
current guardian this explains why grace
is extremely mad at our arrival in
pauper's drop claiming that we stole
eleanor from her the reason this is
relevant is because all this information
is key to understanding her character
and thus determining her fate at the end
of the level bioshock 2 introduces the
option of killing or sparing three key
people and our first is grace holloway
when you enter grace's quarters you're
given the choice of killing or sparing
her it's quite easy to just kill her and
leave since she started fighting you but
given her backstory i ultimately decided
to spare her she was just a poor and
lost woman down in rapture and when
sophia was able to bring her out of her
own hell of course she was going to help
her as much as she could plus we can't
blame her for not understanding the bond
between eleanor and delta neither wanted
to become little sisters or big daddies
even as an alpha series model yes your
skin isn't grafted to the suit but
you're still heavily spliced with adam
and of course as we know most if not all
the big daddies were unwilling
participants we never chose this life
but grace doesn't know that so we can't
blame her for trying to kill us if you
spare her she goes on to say that she
was wrong about you she still believes
that sophia isn't a liar but she knows
that she is at least wrong about delta
our second character is stanley pool at
diana's park still continuing to be
altruistic sophia also had a hand in the
creation of the park which served as a
both an art and cultural exhibit hosted
by sophia herself she created this as
both a way for her to undermine ryan's
ideals and also a way to promote her own
ryan's main philosophy with rapture was
a city without morals or sensors so
naturally all art should be accepted in
rapture until sophia started using this
against him and started showcasing art
opposite of ryan's ideology this of
course led to her art being censored by
the general public showing that rapture
was a place that accepted these
qualities but as long as ryan agreed to
it to make matters worse for ryan his
own version of this was arcadia from
bioshock 1 except ryan charged his
visitors whereas sophia made this
exhibit free to the public due to this
attack on his character ryan had enough
of lam and sent a spy to infiltrate her
network this spy was stanley pool
stanley was quite successful in feeding
information to ryan but so much so that
it led to sofia being imprisoned he
would then during this time used the
money sophia had to throw parties at the
park in an attempt to eradicate her
funds however during this time eleanor
caught wind of these parties and
confronted stanley about it fearing he
would be caught he was the one who
kidnapped eleanor and gave her up to the
little sisters orphanage in the present
day stanley has flooded the exhibit
fearing that sophia and the other
members in the family would rat him out
as ryan's spy he stays held up in there
for years until delta arrives at the
park while we're only here to just pass
by and get to fontaine futuristic
stanley refuses to let us pass until we
deal with all the little sisters despite
all the witnesses being dead stanley
fears that when the little sisters drain
the victims adam they'll discover the
truth and relay the info back to sophia
so he wants us to get rid of them but by
helping the little sisters we can also
uncover the full story for ourselves
what is shown is the info we just
previously went over with him kidnapping
eleanor and throwing massive parties at
sofia's expense when we approached
stanley sophia hops on the microphone
and says that he is the reason we're a
big daddy and that she knew for years
that he was a spy we are now once again
given the option of killing or sparing
him this decision was probably the
hardest one for me to do stanley is
responsible for our new life but he
wasn't the only one at fault he wrote
the article about delta being the
mysterious deep-sea diver the article
didn't seem like it was malicious ryan
was the only one who saw delta as a
threat so the blame now goes to ryan but
ryan just simply imprisoned us it was
sinclair who would then offer us a job
at fontaine futuristics as a performer
who tested plasmids in front of a live
audience these performances made him a
candidate for the big daddy program so
sinclair is now to blame but dr su chong
and gilbert alexander created the big
daddy program so they're to blame as
well do you see where this is going no
one person is truly responsible for
delta's new life it was just coincidence
after coincidence and he was just at the
wrong places at the wrong time every
time you could however claim that
because he hurt eleanor and turned her
into a little sister he should be
punished but this argument is quite
shallow all of these decisions that
happened between us and eleanor led to
us being bonded together but if
something changed then we could have
been bonded with someone else say we
arrived later or even earlier to rapture
then eleanor would have likely never
bonded with us so there is no argument
in saying that we should harm stanley
for how we treated eleanor because not
only did we not know her even prior to
our own transformation you could
technically even argue that we should be
grateful to him for bringing us together
although i don't really subscribe to
that idea either despite this there is a
lot of reasons to not spare him and that
is because of his other actions like
killing the witnesses and clearly
showing that he'll do whatever it takes
including murder to get his way it's due
to this confliction that i ultimately
decided to spare stanley he wasn't the
sole reason we're a big daddy and the
idea that we should harm him for what he
did to eleanor makes no sense either our
third and final character is gilbert
alexander his introduction starts off
quite different than what we're used to
as we hear an audio recording tell us to
kill him and then we see him piloting a
security bot all while yelling at a
group of splicers this is quite the
twist as we have a man who is telling us
to kill him because he's going to become
clinically insane but then also having
that new insane self tell us not to kill
him it's also during this level where we
can meet mark meltzer the guy who
investigated rapture so he could find
his daughter or at least what was left
of him anyway it seems that despite all
he went through he was caught by sophia
and turned into a big daddy on the plus
side however according to the audio log
that was found in his body the little
sister he bonded with was his daughter
cindy so at least they got to be
together forever well at least until we
killed him you don't discover that this
is mark until after his death which
makes you feel quite sad as you just
tore his daughter from him so i made it
up to mark by restoring his daughter to
her former self in hopes that she can
have a brighter future it's incredible
how bioshock makes you care about mark
and cindy despite them rarely ever
showing up you know what happens to the
little girls in rapture so that makes
the situation even worse as we now
finally got to see the other side of the
coin we're not able to see how the
parents react to their daughter being
taken bioshock 1 did this as well with
another individual but i felt it was
much better handled here going back to
gilbert since we have to decide his fate
the question is then what's his story
well gilbert alexander was a researcher
at rapture who specialized in robotic
and mechanical engineering he was also
the creator of the alpha series big
daddies and was responsible for the
unbreakable bond that they have built
into them as we know it worked too well
making them not as efficient and
protecting all the little sisters as it
only made them care about one this idea
was inevitably thrown out but due to his
knowledge of the bonding process and the
manufacturing of the suits he assisted
dr sung in creating the new line of big
daddies after some time though he began
to feel guilty about his actions sofia
used the skill to manipulate him into
being her own test subject
dr alexander has agreed to accept both
measures of the new utopian project
he will become a kind of genetic chimera
host to all the minds of rapture
accessing their talents and memories via
the adam we have gathered
and deriving in part from project wyk
i have developed a new set of behavioral
constraints
dr alexander will live to promote the
common good she wanted to use gilbert as
a test subject to see if she could
create the first utopian being capable
of losing self-interest and being
extremely loving and loyal to the human
race this however did not go as planned
i was to be sophia lamb's greatest
achievement
a living composite of all rapture's
genius in the body of a single man
unfettered by self-interest
now i am nothing more to her than a
failed experiment
my scores on tests of intelligence and
moral reasoning are still noteworthy but
declining sharply
she has abandoned me and i do not have
long before psychosis takes me this is
what led to gilbert making the audio
logs we hear about how to kill him once
he becomes insane after entering the
core of fontaine futuristics we can see
him in his final form which is this
giant amalgamation inside of a water
tank it looks awful we then for the
final time have to decide another
person's fate this is the only person in
the game i killed and i also killed
without hesitation i deemed it as a
mercy killing more than anything this
does become quite the tough argument
when you consider that it's possible
that after being clinically insane he
enjoyed his new life and thus killing
him would have been a bad thing it's
ultimately his words against his own and
personally i'd rather believe the
version that was able to think more
rationally rather than the one that was
mutated beyond human recognition that's
why i felt that it was a good idea to
kill him so i could rid him of his
suffering and allow him to finally die
as a whole these choices were really
well done and judging from some of the
community discussions i've seen and many
have chosen the alternate solutions that
i didn't choose i read many posts saying
that they killed grace holloway for
trying to fight them that they killed
stanley for turning us into a big daddy
and some even spared gilbert because
they believed that his past self wants
to die but his present self doesn't want
to and thus they spared him this shows
that these choices were well written
enough that it wasn't clear what the
best choice was in the moment makes you
think about your decision and what led
to things being like how they are now
and that's once again extremely
impressive after dealing with gilbert we
make it to persephone which is rapture's
prison system and is also where we find
eleanor as we approach her sophia stops
us and locks us out she goes on to
explain that eleanor wanted a father and
tried to make one again an audio log
clears this up but basically eleanor has
the power to control the little sisters
and through this power she managed to
find a gene sample of delta she planned
on using this sample to revive delta
through a vita chamber and sure enough
it worked this explains how we survived
the gunshot wound we didn't actually
survive eleanor just revived us she also
used the little sisters to contact
tenenbaum so that she could help us get
back up on her feet now things are
starting to make a bit more sense but
just as we're about to be let inside
sophia smothers eleanor with a pillow
temporarily stopping us due to our
unbreakable bond however it was only for
a specific amount of time as sophia
obviously wants to keep eleanor alive as
that's literally her daughter so it
wasn't enough time to kill her but it
was enough to break our bond with her
when we awake we're strapped down and
can't move but eleanor lets us take
control of one of the little sisters so
that we can unlock our own restraints as
simple as this sequence was it was
probably one of my favorites in the
entire game as we got to see the world
through the eyes of the little sister
for the very first time and it truly
shows how deep the mental conditioning
went they don't even see the same world
that we do it's completely different
this was more than likely made so that
the girls didn't have to see the horrors
of the real world and thus can continue
to do their jobs without being scared
this explains why everything is so clean
and new in their world and why the big
sister suit isn't a diving suit but a
dress and why there's petals instead of
blood when we do extract the blood from
the splicers though it does come back to
the real world and i don't think this
happens to the girls i think it's just
more of a game design decision to remind
us that we're still in rapture meaning
the girls after becoming little sisters
never see the real world again until we
save them this was such a great section
and really shows how badly their minds
were altered after using the little
sister to gather the big sister suit we
give it to eleanor who uses it to break
out of her containment and then release
us as well we also get a plasmid that
can summon her from any location which
is really cool as it shows sophia that
despite the bond being physically broken
their love for one another knows no
bounds by talking with eleanor we
discover that she has a plan which is to
take sinclair's lifeboat up to the
surface except sophia is trying to stop
us while trying to thwart her plans at
stopping us we run into sinclair again
except time this is not on good terms it
seems that he was captured and made into
a big daddy we can hear his voice over
the radio getting more and more
desperate as he tries to find a way out
of the suit he then tells us to unlock
the door and finish him off even though
he desperately wanted to live and be on
the surface again dying is better than
being a controlled test subject after
getting the device from sinclair and
also helping eleanor rescue the little
sisters that are in the nearby wing we
use the little sisters by having them
boil the water underneath the lifeboat
so it can rise i'll be honest i don't
remember if this was ever explained in
the entire series ever but the only
thing i can assume is that they're
expelling the atom in their systems
which heats the water somehow as we
finish heating the lifeboat the
explosives that sofia planted explode
and cause us to get knocked back
thankfully we're just barely able to
latch onto the lifeboat as it floats up
and it's here where we discover the
ending of the game but it's done a bit
differently this time there are six
possible endings but it's all because of
the combination of two choices the
harvesting and rescuing from bioshock 1
returns again but the sparing and
killing of the previous characters is
also a factor there's actually a neat
little flow chart someone made to help
visualize them sparing lives actually
has different weight depending on your
choices with the little sisters if you
spared all the girls then saving one
character will give you the best ending
but if you harvest a couple of little
sisters then you must spare all of them
to get that same ending this goes even
further with the bad ending as when you
harvest all the little sisters sparing
the three characters is still not enough
and then you're stuck in the bad ending
now this is only for determining whether
or not sofia lives the other decision is
eleanor and delta's fate if you rescue
all the little sisters then eleanor will
drain delta's adam and transfer it into
her so that his memories and
consciousness can live inside of her and
the two can be together forever if you
harvest all the little sisters eleanor
shows no remorse and drains all of his
adam for herself killing delta as she
says that we taught her not to let
things go to waste however these endings
are different from bioshock 1 and not
just in the actual cutscenes but it's
how it's determined remember eleanor can
control and look through the eyes of the
little sisters because of this she was
able to witness all the rescuing and
harvesting we did to them as well as the
decisions we made regarding the three
important people we discussed before and
it's these decisions that play into the
ending of the game whereas bioshock 1
had a similar structure which changed
the ending based on our decisions with
the sisters it's not outlandish to find
this a bit odd as some could have simply
just used the sisters for extra atom to
survive rapture and had no intentions of
taking the girls for themselves or using
them in the splices to rule rapture but
with bioshock 2 your decisions don't
affect you but your own daughter just as
a parent can influence their child's
behavior we as the parent influenced
eleanor's outlook on life such as
whether or not people should be forgiven
for their past mistakes and a bit more
directly eleanor got to see how caring
and ruthless delta was like i said
earlier when we get the bad ending she
explains how we taught her not to let
things go to waste and that bad people
should be punished for their actions no
matter how small or insignificant they
were this adds another layer to the
endings overall as these aren't just
decisions that affect the ending of the
game but decisions that affect elvenar
which then affect the ending of the game
this was mind-blowing what i had looked
into the endings and how they were
determined and it's just outright
incredible while the ending of bioshock
2 marks the end of the game it's not
really the end of the game as bioshock 2
came with a couple dlcs one of which was
a side story called minerva's den as
opposed to the main game minerva's then
takes a bit longer to set up the story
instead of our main character being
subject delta we now play a subject
sigma another alpha series big daddy as
we approach a tunnel it gets blown up
and we're sent into the sea floor we
hear a man on the radio named charles
milton porter who instructs us to find
the thinker we then eventually get
introduced to reed wall both him and
porter were the founders of this device
called the thinker which is great except
we don't know what it is of course in
typical bioshock fashion an audio log
explains it instead the thinker is a
giant computer that uses atom to process
data at the speed of thought it's the
sole reason that rapture can even
operate it's quite a neat device but
both reid and porter discovered it could
do so much more this is what caused a
split between the two founders reed
wanted to use the thinker as a
prediction machine so it can bet on the
ball games and see the changes in the
stock market but porter wanted to create
artificial intelligence but more
specifically he just wanted to replicate
the mind of his dead wife pearl who died
during a german bombing during our
travels through minerva's den we can
also find some audio logs of tenenbaum
which explains why she disappeared
during the main story she was trying to
find a cure for adam adam and the
sickness that comes with repeated use is
the main reason rapture turned out this
way in the first place and if tenenbaum
can find a cure she can not only help
those who are still alive within rapture
but also be able to take this and the
plasmids to the surface with the safety
of knowing that whatever happened in
rapture won't happen again she sadly
hasn't gotten very far in her research
as there is still a ton of variables
that require calculation which is why
she wants the thinker as she believes it
could solve her problem instantly this
is why she works with porter as they
both want the thinker to survive so they
can use it for good on the surface this
is a much better introduction and now
provides the reason as to why we're
tasked with finding the device in the
first place is we can now change the
world with the thinker the only problem
is we don't know who we are however that
will be explained a bit later sadly
though after this there isn't much in
terms of a present day story the main
game suffers the same problem where it's
really just one objective that you need
to complete like finding eleanor which
takes the entire game however bioshock 2
splits up this objective by forcing you
to interact with new people and even
make some decisions except minerva's
then doesn't do that from the start to
the end the main objective is to stop
reid and find the thinker there are no
other characters present in this dlc
besides reed porter tenenbaum and sigma
you don't make any choices and there is
only one ending so it's really just a
long string of tedious objectives that
are broken up by more combat i said the
same thing in bioshock 1 when talking
about the arcadia and market levels
taking into account the gameplay the
exploration and the story these levels
flow really well and are fun to have
combat encounters in but when just
looking at the story itself it suffers
there just really isn't anything going
on it's like the dlc has a heavy focus
of story in the beginning and the end of
the playthrough while the combat takes
up the middle thankfully the audio logs
do break up some of the pace and allow
for more story to creep in but all this
is story from the past i'm talking about
things that are happening in the here
and now like once again how we learn
about the three characters in the main
story then choose to spare or kill them
or when we finally meet eleanor but then
sophia stops us by breaking our bond
together these are things that are
happening in the present and are shaping
the story the dlc does not have any of
that the first level of the game is
about going from one area to the next
grabbing items so you can open up new
areas until you finally complete the
whole level this continues all the way
up to the final few minutes of the game
as all we're really trying to do is just
make it to the core of the central
computing wing so we can find the
thinker throughout the whole time in
this dlc most of our interactions with
these people is just porter giving us
instructions and reid projecting a very
cocky attitude because he believes that
the thinker can stop us since it can
predict any outcome except later we
discover that isn't entirely true it is
calculating what we'll do but according
to the equation once we reach the core
it just stops this worries him as the
outcome is undetermined something pretty
much impossible to happen to the thinker
this problem of his happens around the
time we enter his office and it's where
we discover that because of this beef
reed took it upon himself to frame
porter for a crime he didn't commit and
have him thrown in jail since he was in
jail the thinker would be his to control
and now he could use it for whatever he
wants but the thinker never chose reid
as much as he thinks this to be the case
in fact i don't think it really chose
anyone however it did assist porter
well thinker
ryan secret police are on their way
they cooked up some kind of evidence
against me treason they say
i've heard what happens to folks who get
disappeared come back as one of those
metal daddies
so i'm leaving you with something to
cogitate on in my absence
inputting rapture departure protocol
figure a way to get yourself out of this
city thinker you've got to live on no
matter what happens to me
so before being shipped off to prison
porter created a program so that the
thinker could escape reed's grasp this
makes sense as when we enter the last
few minutes of the game reed discovers
that the thinker wasn't working with him
but against him it's also around this
time where reed expresses his confusion
as to how porter walked out of
persephone unscathed and an idea came
into my head and for the very first time
in this series i finally predicted
something because we discover that
subject sigma is charles milton porter
going back to that rapture departure
protocol the thinker determined that the
best possible way for him to escape was
to enlist the help of porter himself to
get sigma to follow the thinker he used
the personality duplication program
which is what porter designed when he
tried to replicate his wife but the
thinker instead replicated porter's own
mind besides being a bit of an obvious
twist i was happy that i did manage to
guess this and the plot twisted in
general was really nice as it does solve
the question of why sigma is even
following orders to begin with i'm just
really glad that they cleared up that
question by still continuing to use the
bioshock formula of a weird plot twist
that ties the whole story together after
this revelation we get to explore
porter's office and find an audio
recording of his time with ai pearl i
believe i'm done feeding audio
recordings and personal anecdotes to the
thinker
i am set to test the
personality duplication function
target personality
pearl porter
thinker
are you ready
yes elton
starting test
hello
pearl
how have you been
just wonderful milton
i've missed you though
it's been so long
pearl
i
no
no this isn't right it isn't her
thinker stop the test
but what's the matter milton
don't you still love me oh god oh god i
said i said end function thinker
now
it's over
i'll admit i've seen this exact
situation tons of time in other media
and this usually ends with a person
dedicated to the machine and desperately
wanting their significant other back
porter though immediately recognized the
problems with doing something like this
so good job on porter for breaking the
mold a bit and not succumbing to your
own creation on a more serious note this
technology while impressive does have
some adverse effects on the user as we
heard with porter as great as this
technology is the duplication program
should not be used ever again and i
think porter agrees as we go further
down the lower halls of the office we
can see a memorial for pearl meaning he
still hasn't been able to move on from
the incident and honestly who can really
blame him at the very bottom though is a
bathysphere and inside is tenenbaum with
the thinker in good hands and the two
safe from harm tenenbaum plans to find
the cure for adam so she could change
porter back to who he once was after
that is finished he'll then look into
all the others back in rapture but we
don't know what exactly happens we do
see parts of the suit on the ground and
someone standing by a grave which we can
assume is porter meaning that he was
able to become a human again overall we
get a very happy ending the cure for
atom is complete meaning the residents
of rapture can eventually return to
being normal again adam and plasmids can
now be used by the general public in a
safe and secure manner and porter was
able to move on and say goodbye to his
wife is a nice conclusion to the game
and also a nice conclusion to the
rapture's story
bioshock 2 as a whole really showcased
how stellar the writing of this series
is it took the concepts from bioshock 1
and had them fit and connect really well
with new concepts introduced in bioshock
2 which ultimately created this seamless
story with very little if any plot holes
or continuity problems and it also
managed to create a compelling story
both about delta and his journey but all
the other inhabitants like mark meltzer
gilbert alexander stanley and many other
characters we hear from the actual
foundation of this story was also
brilliant as bioshock 1 introduces a
ruler with a specific outlook on life in
a city created based around that ideal
but then bioshock 2 changes the
narrative by introducing sophia a
character with an outlook on life that
is directly opposite of ryan's we then
get to see these two ideologies clash
and then inevitably burn by our hands
once again this is why i said in the
beginning that i believe bioshock 2 is
perfect it's story and while not the
topic of this video it's gameplay where
without any flaws it's just a shame
though that this game gets overshadowed
by its predecessor i do completely
understand why though is that plot twist
is one of the best if not the best in
gaming history but it's because of this
attention that all our eyes are centered
on the first game rather than the second
and i don't think bioshock 2 deserves
that it took what was great about the
previous game's narrative structure and
applied it to its own game while also
changing things that went wrong such as
the lack of world building outside of a
few key characters bioshock 2 is perfect
and from a story perspective arguably
even better than its previous
installment with bioshock 2 and
minerva's then complete we now
officially come to the end of the video
and thank you all for watching a lot of
you wanted me to discuss the sequel and
i was more than happy to do so however
we still aren't done with bioshock just
yet so look out in the future for a
video on bioshock infinite now that
there's been a few videos in this style
where we go very in-depth on a game's
story in particular let me know how you
like these especially in comparison to a
more typical analysis that would also
cover combat and exploration with that
make sure to like and subscribe if
you're new for more videos like this and
if you haven't seen the previous video
on bioshock 1 then i highly recommend
you check that out as always thank you
to my returning viewers for coming back
and with that take care everyone
goodbye
[Music]
you